i saw this man last night in so far
stadium i saw him i had my son with me
coop was hanging with me last night did
westwood one radio for pregame halftime
this man did the
uh local broadcast of the los angeles
rams he is none other than maurice jones
drew how you doing mjd
i'm doing well rich how are you i
appreciate it you're traveling back home
already i i appreciate the phone call
here i i started the show saying
that this is the best the rams have
looked all year and that they're
they're set to win in a way that they
they
they they weren't even earlier this year
when they started as well as they did
how do you how do you take that one mjd
i think you're i think you're exactly
right rich uh when you look at the way
the rams started obviously
uh you know they say they started out
hot they were playing well but they had
some struggles you had some turnovers by
matthew stafford they really they were
running the ball but it wasn't as
explosive um and then defensively they
weren't causing turnovers they were just
getting stops and you know third down
stops so you look at what happened last
night you kind of look at what happened
throughout december after the bond
miller trade you're starting to see more
sacks you start to see pressure from
different guys
troy reader with the big time hit on the
quarterback i thought was going to be a
safety but
he turned it into a big six so now
they're being opportunistic um
defensively and then the other part is
offensively cam akers is just a
different monster when hit with him in
the backfield i mean he just looks
completely different that's no shade of
the other guys other guys sony michelle
and darrell henson did a really good job
but you see a difference with cam makers
there with his ability out of the
backfield to uh run routes or to light
up a receiver and uh have a mismatch on
linebackers and then last but not least
special teams
i mean special teams was like a achilles
heel for the rams uh the first month
first half of the season and it just
started getting better and better than
to have those punts downed inside the
tin
uh to give kyle murray that offensive
long field to continue to put pressure
on them every time they came out
was something the rams often capitalize
on and then you know matthew stafford
not turning the ball over is really what
you're looking for
you know what the the the
they're just cam akers is a difference
maker he really is and i know that we
don't have much to go on because of you
know his rookie season and clearly this
year was a washout up until right now
but i mean
he he you know he's a match-up problem
you know uh outside the numbers too as
we saw a couple times
last night he's got burst he can he can
also break tackles he's somebody that if
he's fresh-legged right and and can
actually get 20 something touches a game
that's the difference maker here
in the entire playoffs for the rams you
could say you could make a dark case
yeah i'll tell you this much when you
scouted him out of florida state you
really didn't see that the last couple
years or the last year because it was a
different coast but when he had jimbo
fisher you saw all that you saw the
vision you saw the elusiveness
you saw the ability to catch out of the
backfield to make guys miss um the
suddenness uh he kind of checked down
in the game and they got called back for
holding made one guy missing was 20
yards up the field in the blink of an
eye so
yeah he brings a different element to
the game and you have to understand this
as well he's only going to get better
because he's missed the whole season so
he didn't he played he had flashes
against the niners in week 18. he saw
what he was able to do last night
against the cardinals and he's going to
just keep getting better and so
he just brings a different element and
you're right rich when they when they
put him out at wide receiver and a lot
of times they would put run they'll put
running backs out there just kind of be
a decoy and you're just a guy
but they'll throw him the ball and he
ran past um one of the linebackers for
the cardinals i don't remember which one
and matthew stafford threw a ball he
just could he just didn't track it all
the way but i tell you what that would
have been a touchdown too and that would
have been a different battle really blew
this game wide open maurice jones drew
here on the rich eisen show what's your
assessment of arizona haven't seen him
last night in person well this is the
thing arizona always starts hot they
they start hot and then they all you
know for some reason they just tell off
at the end of the year so why is that
why would that possibly what could
something like that be attributed to
everybody's throwing it on the coach
because he had the same problems
in his five years at texas in college so
what do you got for me on that do you
think it's a run game it's not having a
consistent run game right when your your
quarterback is a part of it that you
know the read option that doesn't work
in the national football league late in
the year you have to be able to turn
around and hand the football off and
they showed elements and flashes of that
last night but it wasn't consistent
right and i think a lot of times
we get caught up in this air raid thing
we want to throw the ball and it's
awesome but to win football games the
national football league late in the
year you have to be able to turn around
and hand the football off and your
offensive line needs to go forward not
sideways and when you do that you start
to wear on the defense and listen i get
it tyler murray uh is a tremendous
athlete but he wasn't willing to run
last night either and that was a problem
too
if if i'm cliff kingsbury i'm saying
listen we only have one game
a one game season i need you to break
some tackles or make some guys miss to
start getting yards did you not see josh
allen against the new england patriots
right and we're not playing in zero
degree weather so we need to utilize our
str our strengths which is kyla's arm
and his legs and so they didn't utilize
that at all and down the stretch that
becomes a problem and so if you look at
a lot of the games they'll they'll run
out of shotgun they do a lot of those
things but it's not consistent enough
and throwing short passes to the
sidelines or screens to the sidelines
that doesn't count as a running game uh
mentally now in the stats you could say
hey it's just a short pass it's the same
as a run
but running the ball is a mentality and
right now the cardinals don't have that
mentality to go out and win the games on
the road in the playoffs maurice jones
drew here on the rich eisen show okay so
now we get a rematch of the week three
uh contest in sophie it was the first
loss of the year
for tampa uh the rams won that football
game they knocked gronk out of it
remember gronk missed some time with
some broken ribs that's the game in
which he suffered that injury uh they
beat him up uh and took care of business
what about the rematch now with all the
chips on the line in a title defense for
tampa
yeah i think it's gonna be a little bit
different uh the nozbe week um obviously
tampa is completely different
uh with guys being injured or you know
obviously maybe not being there i know
you guys talked about that
um but this is the thing it's it's their
offensive line is really good tristan
works can't come back or he if his ankle
or foot or whatever he hurt against
philadelphia is that bad it's going to
be an issue for them because the rams
defensive line now i'll say this the
rams offensive line has a big task as
well because
this defensive front for
the tampa bay buccaneers are getting
after the quarterback uh they're
stopping the run they're doing all the
things right that they weren't doing in
december
and they're playing more confident i
don't know if it's because uh
david's back out there or if it's
because you know they just simplify some
things that are playing man and man
across the board uh but those safeties
are playing well uh the linebackers are
fitting the run the right way so it's
going to be a tough task don't get me
wrong the question is if you play
man-to-man who's going to cover cooper
cup and odell beckham julian i think
that's gonna be a match-up you need that
we need to keep our eye on and then on
the other side how does mike evans uh
fare against jaylen ramsey right um
they're gonna lock him up you don't have
chris godwin to kind of be the guy that
you have to go to so it's going to be
chris evans and gronk and how's the rams
cover him and how do they affect tom
brady in the pocket so
it's going to be a great matchup um
obviously i'm going to go with the rams
just because i work for him right it
only makes sense that i do that yes um
but it's hard to go against the goat as
well so it's going to be a terrific
matchup but i can't wait i know the rams
are excited um to still be playing i
know they're excited to
kind of you know get back on the road a
little bit and and trying to face some
of those demons they've had on the road
this year
uh and then the other part is this is
matthew stafford you know you were
brought here to be the guy to lead them
to a super bowl can you do that can you
be that guy and the only way to do it is
oh i i think the best way to do it is
going between the greatest of all time
and i think that'll prove a lot
here for the rams well i mean because
brady one would think
would exploit the depth problems the
rams have at safety in a way that the
the cardinals didn't even
you know attempt it seemed yesterday or
weren't able to pull off right i mean
how about that as a problem like giving
giving giving gronk and breit and howard
a try in between the the hashes over and
over and over again your thoughts on
that you would think zach earth would
have had a huge day right i don't know
what the hell that was i honestly don't
i mean
murray murray looked so
fast with his feet and his decisions
it's just like you know i said again i
date myself it's like playing a 33
record on 78 speed you know like it was
that's what it looked like last night to
me well the thing yeah the thing is this
i mean the reason a lot of that happened
was because the defensive line was
getting to murray early right they were
touching them they're around them the
pocket was collapsing on them and that's
how you help that back in now obviously
the the bucks have a different offensive
line and
a bigger stronger one than than arizona
so it's gonna be tougher but anytime you
have injuries on the back end the front
end and i know warren sapp was one of
our colleagues at one time he's always
telling you they work they work they
work together right so
when one is down the other has to pick
up the slack and you saw that bob miller
with a big sack early in the start that
game aaron donald and greg gaines
getting tremendous pressure leonard
floyd always around the quarterback the
more you can do that and affect tom
brady as we know if you get around him
with rushing four and he gets to get
those happy feet that's what you want
and that's how you're going to protect
you know obviously nick scott and
terrell burgess and you know eric weddle
again a guy who you know gives us oh
give us gives us a retired guys hope
that maybe we can play again maybe there
is a chance that if i get in shape
you know
if they make the playoffs if they make
the show not the playoffs they make the
super bowl that i get a couple weeks to
kind of get right and maybe i get a goal
line character do you like your seed
you're the cg anderson possibility
of the sausage you
i can give you cj right now i just want
to be you i want to be a better version
of me though what should jacksonville do
with their head coach
you know this is a big one um i think
when you know i've talked to a lot of
people in that organization
um i think it's important that
you kind of go the rams route
and then a lot of guys have done it um
when you draft a quarterback first
overall and all those things you got to
put as much quarterback knowledge around
if you want your head coach to have
quarterback knowledge you want your um
obviously offensive coordinator to have
it you want to have a quarterback
coasters knowledge well then an older
guy in the room and so
to me if you're going to go and look for
a guy to be that you want you want those
attributes in your head coach you want a
guy that's won
coaching quarterbacks or has played
coaching quarterbacks uh so whoever that
guy may be
obviously you know i know a lot of
people i've been a big advocate for jim
caldwell doug peterson byron leftwich
those are guys i think jacksonville
that they should look at guys that have
been there and to be honest byron
leopards the guy when i was there
was the fir was a quarterback draft in
the first round he understands it
um
he understands the pressures that many
of us may not know
what it takes to play at a high level in
that city
and then also a guy that can relate in
that locker room and and make sure that
everyone feels as if their voice is
heard and that they're needed and want
it and so there's a lot of those things
but um i think the jags are doing a
great job of just
kind of doing that net interviewing
everyone and then slowly figuring out
what they want to do there's no rush in
this you want to make sure you get it
right this time exactly and then in the
interview process you told them to make
sure you ask the coach you're not going
to kick the kicker right that's what you
do yeah like yeah we can't touch we
can't test the players right
get on the plane make sure you're flying
the plane got it for we got to come back
on the plane i don't know why we have to
say that but we have to do that we got
to come back on the plane you know we
got to make sure that we're doing all
the little things
uh right um
all right maurice jones drew was good to
see you last night man
oh great to see you as well man and
listen
i think you may need to come to tampa
you may be the secret weapon yes that's
me it's me i was there i was there the
first night against chicago too
so yeah yeah i'm telling you maybe your
son and tell him he was there too
my whole hershey bar so tell him i have
a bunch of hershey bars for him yeah by
the way you know he he saw like i
brought koopa in just so he could see
his first ever press
uh feedback oh the room yeah spread and
so maurice is just like see the candy on
the top there that's all for you that's
what he said
i'm like thanks maurice my gosh did he
snag it yeah he got he got one he got in
there he was he was a great kid he
didn't want to really you know my kids
would have been like stealing stuff
thank you
take care of yourself
are you too rich it's the great mjd
right here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here